bienvenue à tous et leurs deux
parlements et 2 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire semaines très chargées
vois ça avec marion le fait bon jour
majoritaire wario une semaine marquée
loupe par les élections sénatoriales
wernick la droite reprend le sénat forte
poussée des centristes autre
enseignement de ce scrutin la gauche
reculent dans les territoires deux élus
du front national font également leur
entrée le nouveau président du sénat
s'appelle gérard larcher le gouvernement
a dévoilé son budget pour 2015 une
difficile équation l'état est à la diète
il doit baisser ses dépenses mais il
fait un geste vers les ménages 3
millions d'entre eux devraient sortir de
l'impôt le déficit public lui continue
de filer et le gouvernement à sion aux
2,9 côté séries politique entre fiction
et réalité les hommes de lons et la
série politique française est bien
entame sa deuxième saison avec l'actrice
carole bouquet
et pour commenter cette semaine
politique est notre invité est philippe
dallier bonjourbonjour vice président du
groupe ump au sénat ce sénateur de
seine-saint-denis alors vous incarnez
avec bruno retailleau le renouveau du
sénat juste qu'aujourd'hui ils vont ne
faisait pas partie des sénateurs les
plus connus du grand public désormais
vice-président du groupe ump vous allez
sans doute y remédier mais sans pour
autant céder aux sirènes des clans de
votre parti alors écoutez comment vos
comptes frères sénateurs analyse ce
renouveau des instances de l'ump moi je
suis vendéen et philippe est élu dans le
9-3 en seine-saint-denis donc c'est le
contraste comme un rajeunissement et
c'est tout à fait
normal et sain pour pour le goût 7,7
pour nous une très bonne équipe
l'équipe très très dynamique et on se
met au travail autour de notre
nos nouveaux présidents et
vice-présidents
ce renouveau c'est vraiment l'image que
vous voulez à donner oui mais je
commencerai par associée catherine des
roches puisqu'il ya un président élu à
bruno retailleau et deux vice présidents
délégués catherine des roches est
également vice présidente déléguée je
crois qu'effectivement une des clés de
lecture de ce scrutin à la présidence du
groupe celle envie de renouveau au cnra
donc il ya une transmission de relais à
une nouvelle génération et je pense que
c'est ce qui explique ce résultat qui
est un résultat très large puisque nous
avons été élus au premier tour de
scrutin ce qui n'était envisagée par
personne et pour tout dire même pas par
nous donc sans surprise aussi pour vous
aimez renouveau renouveau ça veut dire
conclut de la politique comme on le
faisait jusqu'à présent au sénat ont
balayé tout ça va être une nouvelle
façon derrière on balaye tout on verra
en tous les cas je pense qu'il ya une
envie il ya une envie de transparence
une envie de vérité il ya peut-être une
autre manière de faire de la politique
avec un style un peu différente voilà
c'est une autre génération qui prend les
commandes bah écoutez vous en jugerez en
tous les cas une autre génération prend
les commandes et je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose pour le groupe ump est
également pour le sénat parce que il ne
vous aura pas échappé que cette belle
maison est attaquée de toutes parts
parfois à juste raison parfois les
critiques sont très dures et injustes on
va jusqu'à la caricature je pense
qu'effectivement il y as besoin de
changer les choses de changer l'image
mais l'image ça n'est pas tout il faut
aussi effectivement agir pour changer
les choses sur le caddy magister a coûté
il n'est que de lire les grands
hebdomadaires ou d'écouter la radio ou
la télévision cette maison et cathy
caricaturer on la présente comme la
maison de retraite avec des gens qui ne
font rien ou pas grand chose ou un
travail inutile et puis il ya eu un
certain nombre d'affaires qui ont
effectivement fait beaucoup de tort au
sénat et au sénateur donc je pense qu'il
faut maintenant faire en sorte que nous
tournions cette page et que a lyon dans
une direction ou le travail du sénat
sera reconnu pour ce qu'il est et parce
que le sénat de la république c'est une
institution importante alors qu'il ya
des élections au scénar va faire le
bilan c'est lundi
c'est un sénat profondément renouvelée
qui a été élue 88 nouveaux sénateurs
dont 40 femmes on voit tout cela avec
pauline dame
après trois ans de gouvernance
socialiste la droite républicaine
reprend la main au sénat si le mps in
une belle progression avec 145 sièges
lui dis n'est pas en reste avec 11
sièges de plus le ps on perd en revanche
disent les communistes 4 tandis que les
radicaux de gauche sont désormais 12 à
siéger au palais du luxembourg deux élus
front national rejoindre les rangs de la
haute assemblée une tendance qui peut
évoluer jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
date butoir pour choisir son groupe
politique si on est loin de la parité au
sénat elle progresse toutefois lentement
avec désormais 25 % de femmes contre 22
en 2011 quand le palais bourbon en
compte 26 un sénat plus féminin et
légèrement rajeuni avec un âge moyen de
61 ans contre 66 lors du précédent
renouvellement des sénateurs qui reste
plus âgés que les députés avec un écart
moyen de 4 ans maire adjoint présidents
de conseils généraux le sénat reste
encore une assemblée de cumulards avec
plus de trois quarts des élus qui
exercent un ou plusieurs mandats locaux
mais d'ici 2017 date de l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi sur le non cumul des
mandats les sénateurs devront choisir
et notre zoom cette semaine est
consacrée au rôle de cette nouvelle
opposition sénatoriale
a ne va deux bonjour vous êtes
constitutionnaliste vous avez bien sûr
suivi ce retour à droite du sénat quel
va être ce rôle de l'opposition un
sénatoriales aujourd'hui alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est un rôle
j'allais dire qu'il peut s'imaginer se
construire s'inventer ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a eu l'expérience
d'ailleurs certains sont plénier d'un
sénat à droite à la fois dans
l'opposition mais j'allais dire d'un
sénat à droite avec aussi un exécutif de
droite et parfois un sénat qui faisait
de la résistance pour pour dire les
choses simplement d'ailleurs on a tous
je pense le souvenir récent le sénat à
gauche n'étaient pas non plus forcément
une assemblée facile pour pour
l'exécutif donc tout ça pour dire que le
sénat a
j'allais dire une histoire particulière
une manière de travailler qui est
particulière qui peut être du coup fait
mal comprendre aussi cette assemblée qui
contribue à ce que certains aspirent à
sa suppression
ça transforme s est même question que
cette injection ce qui ce qui est sûr
alors c'est je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la vraie question de cette élection je
trouve qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya un
changement tous les sénateurs à qui on a
parlé nous ont dit le danger est bien
c'est qu'on n'existe plus finalement ça
fait 20 ans qu'on dit non donc à chaque
achat alors attendez c'est deux choses
différentes je dire le discours est
récurrent sur faut-il supprimer le sénat
à quoi sert-il et c'est que sans doute
il faille repenser son rôle ou en tout
cas parce que moi je suis convaincu
qu'il a un rôle d'ores et déjà peut-être
un rôle qui n'est pas assez visible mais
le faire savoir et poser aussi la
question si effectivement une réforme
des collectivités devaient survenir de
la manière dont ce sénat devrait à la
fois se saisir de cette réforme il en
sera d'ailleurs saisi en priorité
puisque cela la constitution le prévoit
mais aussi contribué à cela et peut-être
réfléchir à un nouveau rôle du sénat
dans cette confusion comme s'attendre
d'état et que le sénat ait sauvé presque
écoutez je sais pas s'il est en péril a
en péril à ce point il est vrai que les
trois dernières années ont été très
préjudiciable à l'image du caylar
d'abord parce que les grands textes que
le gouvernement présentait était
quasiment systématiquement rejetées et
non pas du fait de l'opposition mais du
fait de la majorité et de son
incohérence politique donc renvoyé le
budget avec une page blanche renvoyait
un certain nombre de textes importants
avec une page blanche il est vrai que
beaucoup on conclut et très vite bon
alors ce moment là le sénat ne sert à
rien ce qui change aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement nous allons pouvoir
adopter des textes alors profondément
remanié et ça va être effectivement le
rôle de l'ump et de lui dit de se
rapprocher et de construire des
propositions alternatives à celles du
gouvernement donc je pense que les
choses vont changer à nouveau
l'assemblée nationale verra arriver des
textes avec des amendements qu'elle
pourra maintenir rappelons que 65% des
amendements votés au sénat ce sont en
général maintenue par l'assemblée
nationale le bicamérisme va faire son
travail de cette fois le bic est
encombrant et je contourne en temps en
temps je pense que le bicamérisme est
important d'abord parce qu'il est dans
la tradition française mais vous dirai
ça les traditions parfois il faut les
changer mais surtout parce qu'il est
utile c'est à dire qu'effectivement le
travail de réécriture et souvent de
débat plus apaisé donc moins visible là
encore sur les textes on le sait ces
traditionnelles ce qui est très vrai
dans ce que disait philippe dallier
c'est que effectivement on a eu une
situation particulière ces trois
dernières années parce que ce que vous
appeliez les grands textes c'est à dire
en fait les textes qui normalement sont
le moment où se soude une majorité et la
majorité où ces jarres et et à gauche
voilà donc le budget le plf est le
projet doit financer la sécurité sociale
sont des taxes on attend que il y ait là
un soutien à la politique du
gouvernement et dans ce cadre là c'est
vrai que sur les trois dernières années
il ya eu un moment je pense
d'incompréhension général qui a conduit
sans doute à ce que ce qui était
satisfait que le sénat passe à gauche
puisque on disait que c'était impossible
se demande si finalement ce n'était pas
une chambre
ingérable quoi quelle que soit sa
configuration politique techniquement
l'une des conséquences est aussi qu'il
n'y aura pas de réforme
constitutionnelle
alors si on raisonne si vous avez
l'étranger
si l'on raisonne en termes de majorité
j'allais dire arithmétique
oui sans doute parce que les majorités
requises sont trop élevés pour que ça
puisse permettre une révision
constitutionnelle
c'était sans doute déjà le cas avant et
j'ajoute que sur le cas particulier par
exemple du droit de vote des étrangers
on se souvient que le sénat bascule en à
gauche l'a immédiatement voter qu'il y
avait par ailleurs des difficultés parce
qu'il fallait que ce soir voté par
l'assemblée et finalement la réforme n'a
pas été à son terme donc oui en même
temps je ne suis pas certaine qu'il
faille toujours des réformes
constitutionnelles je pense qu'il ya sur
un certain nombre de questions des
réformes législatives qui peuvent avoir
un effet institutionnels tout aussi
significatif et que donc il faut pas se
focaliser alors que ce soit la réforme
des collectivités que ce soit puisque
c'est un peu dans l'air du temps aussi
la question d'éventuelles d'une réforme
des modes de scrutin certains aspirent à
l'introduction de la proportionnelle ce
sont des questions dont en tout c'est
d'ailleurs en résulte est donc en toute
tranquillité indépendamment même et
partage droite bush ont tout ceci vient
dans les assemblées à novak vous restez
avec nous on va passer au mardi mais
parce que on va parler d'une primaire à
droite à l'ump a choisi son candidat
sont candidats pour le sénat bien
évidemment est le grand gagnant de cette
primaire à droite et l'ancien président
du sénat gérard larcher qui a devancé
très largement au premier tour l'ancien
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin et
philippe marini philippe dallier on a
beaucoup évoqué cette question est-ce
que c'était à votre politique ou pas
politique au sens vous avez entendu à
vous très bientôt population entre
nicolas sarkozy françois signaux et
d'autres ça n'était pas la seule grille
de lecture mais je pense qu'il fait
normalement oui et c'est peut-être la
principale malgré tout et je l'avais dis
pour ma part à jean pierre raffarin je
pense que le choix des sénateurs s'est
aussi fait en fonction de l'actualité à
l'ump et au regard de leur volonté
d'indépendance ça je pense que c'est ce
qui a marqué ce scrutin jean pierre
raffarin
fait le choix de s'afficher alors qu'il
faisait partie du trio puis fait
toujours partie du triumvirat à la tête
de l'ump il s'est engagé derrière
nicolas sarkozy et certains ont eu
effectivement peur que le sénat ne
devienne effectivement une antichambre
de la rue de vaugirard dans le lit
vraiment content pour certains si vous
finalement mais attendez pour certains
vous savez vous avez 143 ya 143 membres
dans le groupe je pense que les raisons
sont certainement différente d'une
personne à l'autre mais je pense que la
volonté d'indépendance du groupe ump au
sénat est certainement une des raisons
principales de la victoire au premier
tour et aussi nettement de gérard roche
et les sénateurs ont revendiqué une
liberté de vote ils sont rebelles 7
sénateurs
écoutez oui je vais envie de vous dire
oui parce qu'on l'a vu sur un certain
nombre de textes vous savez quand on
était au gouvernement moi je me souviens
à l'époque avec une trentaine de
sénateurs du groupe ump on avait dit on
ne votera pas la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle en l'état et en art à
l'époque fait reculer le gouvernement et
le texte a été profondément modifiée à
quoi sert-il d'être parlementaire si on
met toujours ce que l'on pense au plus
profond de soi sous son mouchoir et si
on se range systématiquement à la vie de
la formation politique on a envie
d'indépendance et c'est peut-être aussi
ce que les français nous réclame sortir
de la langue de bois dire ce que nous
pensons et agir en conséquence
ça ne vas tu votes pour notamment gérard
larcher pour vous ça vous a surpris ou
pas qui sont les murs des premiers temps
on nous a lancé un match tellement serré
oui il faut toujours se méfier j'allais
dire des annonces pour il y avait il y
avait trois candidats je crois que les
candidats étaient assez différent et
sans doute effectivement les éléments de
contexte ont-ils pu
jouer cela dit c'est vrai aussi que
gérard larcher a l'expérience pour le
coût de la présidence de finale
j'entendais tout à l'heure évoqué le
renouvellement au sein du groupe il me
semble pas forcément d'ailleurs
incohérent qui ait eu un choix de entre
guillemets continuité pour la présidence
du sénat et au contraire de profond
renouvellement au sein de l'ump c'est
peut-être finalement une sorte une forme
d' équilibre interne dans le cadre du
choix du groupe ce renouveau c'est ce
que vous voulez incarner cette
indépendance côté rebelle des sénateurs
c'est la marque ce que vous allez
imprimé sur ce groupe est côté rebelle
écouter on va relativiser mais c'est
vrai que
donc on est plutôt jeune et on a envie
de faire bouger les choses alors on va
essayer de le faire bouger
ce que vous nous avez dit non tous les
cas il est écrit dans la constitution
qu'il n'y a pas de vote impératif choc
parlementaires votent en son âme et
conscience bien évidemment nous
appartenons à un groupe et il faut qu'il
y ait du dialogue de la concertation que
nous essayons ensemble de construire des
textes bon maintenant après chacun se
prononce en son âme et conscience voilà
nous sommes favorables à un sénat le
plus libre et le plus indépendant
possible assène le vase pour cet
éclairage on va continuer à un petit peu
palais du sénat my car l'autre fait
marquant du scrutin c'est l'arrivée du
front national au sénat le parti de
marine le pen et qui a réussi à envoyer
deux sénateurs au palais du luxembourg
qui ont fait une arrivée remarquée marie
vraiment
arrivé devant le sénat à pied pour les
deux sénateurs frontiste vous venez au
sénat pour les supprimer
on vient au sénat pour y travailler
voilà les ce sont les les grands
électeurs qui sont eux-mêmes les
représentants du peuple qui nous ont
demandé de le faire nous allons le faire
avec sérieux comme nous savons le faire
depuis longtemps l'image est forte c'est
la première fois que des élus d'extrême
droite font leur entrée dans la haute
assemblée
un dispositif spécial de sécurité a été
mis en place
un nombre impressionnant de journalistes
a fait le déplacement mais très vite la
question est posée que peuvent faire
deux élus sans groupe le sénateur des
bouches du rhône veut y voir une étape
bien sûr que c'est une étape bien sûr
les élections présidentielles les
élections législatives de député les
élections municipales ces villes
conquises alors qu'on nous disait que
c'était impossible ces élections
européennes et ces élections
sénatoriales qui était la place gardé la
chasse gardée du système
eh bien nous en voyons aujourd'hui les
grands électeurs les français envoie
aujourd'hui deux sénateurs front
national rassemblement bleu marine c'est
une étape de plus il ya la dernière qui
nous tape qui nous tend les bras en 2017
prochain objectif pour les deux
sénateurs trouver leur place au sein du
sénat
david rachline est en effet le benjamin
de l'hémicycle un autre symbole demain
lors de l'élection du président du sénat
c'est lui qui recueillera les votes de
ses collègues sénateur
philippe dallier comment vous analysé
cette élection de deux front national
des grands électeurs décomplexée ou
perdus face à l'état de la politique
aujourd'hui
ces deux élections étaient inscrits ou
quasiment inscrits dans le résultat des
élections municipales de mars dernier il
est quand même à noter effectivement oui
je vais justement préciser les choses
grosso modo le front national pouvait à
l'échelle nationale compter sur un
millier de voix et il semble qu'ils en
aient recueilli 4 milles dans sa montre
aussi effectivement et je pense que
c'est particulièrement vrai dans les
territoires ruraux où les élus sont
assez peu étiqueté politiquement ils
sont souvent sans étiquette il est fort
probable qu effectivement qu'un certain
nombre d'entre eux face aux difficultés
qu'ils connaissent dans l'exercice de
leur mandat eh bien elle choisit de
porter leur voix à faire ces listes qui
ne viennent plus vers vous ni vers la
gauche ceux qui ont fait ce choix là
effectivement quelque part on est même
fait dans un vote de colère on est
presque dans un vote d'adhésion à voter
aux territoires ruraux alors que vous ne
répondrai pas ils sont peut-être pas
généraliser mais c'est vrai que les
collectivités locales et notamment les
plus petites vivent une période
extrêmement difficile la baisse des
dotations de l'état la réforme des
rythmes scolaires scolaire qu'il est
impossible de financer il ya tout un tas
de fuir la disparition des départements
où finalement on ne sait plus où veut
aller le gouvernement donc tous ces
sujets ont profondément marqué la
campagne sénatoriale et je pense
effectivement qu'un certain nombre
d'élus de ces territoires ont choisi de
pousser un coup de gueule en portant
leur voie vers ces listes qu'est ce que
ça change des élus front national à la
haute assemblée est d'accord donc
n'avait pas connu jusque là votre
rapport à ses élus que ce que quand vous
avez vous croisé dans les couloirs
qu'est ce qui va se passer il a rien de
se passer de particuliers moi parce que
j'attends c'est de les voir s'exprimer
en commission et de les voir s'exprimer
en séance voilà c'est moi ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les idées le reste
voilà ce sont des élus de la république
ils sont sénateurs aujourd'hui point
barre souvent on pose la question à
chaque élection à ce qu'il ya un ancrage
aujourd'hui du front national avec cette
élection
il est évident que lors des dernières
élections municipales le front national
a obtenu un certain nombre de voix ils
ont emporté un certain nombre de
collectivités locales donc il faut
effectivement s'interroger sur les
raisons qui ont poussé les français à
choisir ses candidats plutôt que les
lots tous ceux de la gauche on va passer
au mercredi philippe dallier c'est le
grand jour ces jeunes élection au sénat
et c'est donc gérard larcher qui a été
élu au deuxième tour président du sénat
ils accèdent au plateau pour la deuxième
fois après avoir accédé une première
fois entre 2008 et 2011 il promet une
défense des territoires et une
opposition constructive face au
gouvernement on va écouter ses premiers
mots une fois son élection
à la majorité je veux m'adresser pour
lui dire qu'une tâche l'attend est une
opposition constructive avec pour
boussole l'intérêt du pays en ces temps
de difficultés à mes connexio nateur de
l'opposition je veux dire que je serai
le président du sénat de tout le sénat
de tous les sénateurs attentifs à leurs
droits mes chers collègues nous avons
une responsabilité collective il faut
que nous donnions ci n'a plus de force
que nous fassions temps de savoir que
cette question lancinante sur l'utilité
d'une assemblée ne nous soit plus posé
moi j'aimerais qu'on pense que c'est une
opposition constructive ça veut dire
quoi est-ce que vous êtes un opposant de
ni'lin pas ça veut dire que sur certains
textes et en fonction de l'attitude du
gouvernement bien évidemment le sénat
même dans l'opposition au niveau
national pourraient être amenés à
adopter un certain nombre de textes en
les ayant modifié on verra effectivement
quelle est l'attitude du gouvernement
soit consacré 7 effectivement ça c'est
aussi une maîtrise de l'agenda du sénat
qui pourra être une maîtrise j'allais
dire comment la qualifier les je vais
pas dire intelligente mais on sait bien
que si le sénat le veut il peut retarder
les textes du gouvernement nous ne
sommes pas dans cet état d'esprit ce que
nous souhaitons c'est effectivement
pouvoir faire avancer les choses et
notamment sur le sujet des collectivités
territoriales mais ça dépend d'abord de
l'attitude du gouvernement y aura-t-il
une seconde lecture sur le texte que
nous avons examiné avant l'été la
question se posait encore où vous allez
le gouvernement avec le prochain texte
qui va venir sur les régions tout ça est
encore très flou et c'est le
gouvernement qui doit effectivement
faire signe de bonne volonté est ce que
gérard larcher devient aujourd'hui le
principal opposant à manuel valls et
françois hollande
pense pas que l'on puisse dire cela
c'est le président du sénat donc
principal opposant il n'est pas deuxième
personnage de l'état dans l'ordre
protocolaire mais je ne peux pas dire
qu'il est le principal opposant les sens
là plutôt partis politiques mais en tous
les cas ici nous allons examiner les
textes et le gouvernement sera face à la
majorité du sénat et face au président
du sénat qui j'en suis certain aura à
coeur de faire respecter le sénat entre
2008 et 2011 gérard larcher avait
réformer le sénat il avait mis fin des
privilèges est ce que cette réforme va
continuer
j'espère bien parce qu'effectivement on
entend beaucoup de choses là dessus des
choses justes et des choses profondément
erronée qui m'agace parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui les conditions de travail
des sénateurs sont quasiment les mêmes
que celles des députés à très peu de
choses près et on a l'impression en
lisant la presse que ici il y a des
supers privilèges ça n'est pas vrai mais
pour autant je pense qu'il faut aller
plus loin dans un certain nombre de
domaines sur la transparence au sein des
groupes politiques et ça nous allons
nous y atteler pour ce qui concerne à
l'ump
pour parler de la réserve parlementaire
également
verser l'indemnité des sénateurs sur
leur assiduité leur présence ans et
coûter un tout petit effort a été fait
précédemment par jean pierre bel mais à
mon sens c'est trop peu je pense qu'il
faut aller plus loin effectivement il
n'y a pas de raison que les élus les
plus absents et les mêmes conditions que
ceux qui font acte de présence de
manière très régulière
je suis certain qu'il y aura bien plus
loin
mercredi le gouvernement présente à son
budget pour 2015 l'état est à la diète
21 milliards d'euros de baisses de
dépenses cela ne suffira pas pour autant
à contenir le déficit et le gouvernement
l'assument revue de détail des
principales mesures de ce budget avec
elisa bertolo mais
la principale mesure de ce projet de loi
de finances a été annoncée par manuel
valls il ya quelques semaines le
gouvernement entend modifier le barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu
après les 40 milliards de baisses de
charges accordées aux entreprises d'ici
2017 des mesures vont être prises en
faveur des ménages la première tranche
de l'impôt sur le revenu sera supprimé
trois millions de ménages sortiront de
l'impôt 6 millions verront leurs
prélèvements diminué nous avons
également pris la décision d'adapter le
rythme de réduction des déficits à la
situation économique du pays il me
semble utile de donner quelques éléments
d'explication sur ce point
notre politique économique ne change pas
mais le déficit se réduira plus
lentement que prévu du fait des
circonstances économiques très faible
croissance très faible inflation autre
mesure annoncée dans ce plf la hausse de
2 centimes du litre de diesel et une
augmentation de trois euros de la
redevance audiovisuelle
en parallèle le gouvernement poursuit sa
politique d'économies - 7,7 milliards
pour l'état et ses agences - 3 7
milliards pour les collectivités
territoriales - 9,6 milliards pour la
protection sociale objectif réduire le
déficit mais à un rythme ralenti j'avais
parfois entendu dire que c'était une
mesure injuste parce qu'elle aurait
bénéficié à l'heure et bénéficier à tous
non elle bénéficiera aux modestes et
moyens j'ai parfois entendu dire que
puisque ça baissait pour les installer
augmenté pour les autres non il n'y aura
pas d'augmentation d'impôts pour les
autres d'ailleurs 2015 sera la première
année où il n'y aura aucune disposition
dans la loi de finances qui est une
conséquence en terme d'augmentation
d'impôts sur le revenu pour 2015 le
gouvernement prévoit une croissance de
1% et un déficit ramené à 4 3% du pib
des prévisions que la haute autorité des
finances publiques chargées d'émettre un
avis juge fragile est ce que vous
pourriez voter ce budget 2015 tel qu'il
a été très sage je ne je ne crois pas
le problème de ce gouvernement c'est sa
crédibilité en matière économique et
financière depuis qu'ils sont aux
affaires ils n'ont cessé alors de
changer de politique dans un sens
heureusement mais ils ne vont pas assez
loin et il n'y a encore aucun effet le
pack de responsabilité avec les
entreprises pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de traduction concrète mais en matière
budgétaire c'est catastrophe sur
catastrophe
quasiment 100 millions sur son sort il
propose notamment françois fillon mais
ça se fait sur cinq ans ceci étant dit
là c'est 50 milliards sur l'exercice
2015 2016 2017 mais il ya de très gros
doutes parce qu'en fait les économies
que le gouvernement devra réaliser elles
ne sont pas documentés
on ne sait pas encore et on voit bien
d'ailleurs qu'à la première annonce de
réduction de certains crédits on a des
levées de boucliers
les trois sont quasiment nulles et pour
l'inflation effectivement ça sera
également très faible ce qui est un
handicap en matière de création de
richesse donc ce gouvernement navigue à
vue et ne cesse de repousser les
objectifs maintenant c'est peut-être 3 %
en 2017 voilà il ya un manque de
crédibilité totale total et je pense que
le débat au sénat sera intéressant comme
à l'assemblée nationale et j'espère que
le ministre
nous allons pouvoir effectivement adopté
un budget qui sera profondément remanié
donc la commission des finances en tous
les cas pour la majorité va se mettre au
travail et je pense que nous serons en
capacité de proposer un certain nombre
de choses pour aller plus loin et plus
vite parce que l'argument du ministre
est de dire il faut pas effectivement
que les prélèvements tue la croissance
mais il faut peut-être aussi essayer de
faire des économies
plus rapidement et ça on va écouter il
va y avoir un certain nombre de sujets
ils essaient mais à dose homéopathique
je vais vous dire qu'il faudrait les
homéopathiques
sur le non remplacement des
fonctionnaires qui partent à la retraite
effectivement il faut aller plus loin et
plus fort parce qu'on sait que la masse
salariale de l'état et c'est la même
chose pour les collectivités locales
c'est une très grande partie du budget
de l'état et donc ils fonction publique
aussi nicolas sarkozy ne propose mais
moi je moi je serais favorable à ce
qu'on repasse de 35 à 39 heures dans la
fonction publique bien évidemment ça
fait 12 % tout d'un coup alors à effet
différé mais ça représente 12%
effectivement d'économies potentielles
sur la masse globale qui est très
importante si nous ne prenons pas ce
genre de décision nous n'en sortirons
pas et nous n'atteindrons pas nos
objectifs et je vous rappelle qu'on a
dépassé cette semaine et 2000 milliards
d'euros de dettes et que ça c'est un
risque grave hills hotel raft est ce que
vous préconisez drastiques en tous les
cas des mesures certainement plus fortes
que celles qui sont proposées là et ça
va toucher aussi d'ensemble des
françaises sur les impôts que ça vous
fait sur les amis écouter qui peut
croire que nous allons redresser la
france sans que chacun soit mis à
contribution le tout c'est
qu'effectivement les efforts demandés
aux français soit le plus juste et le
plus équilibré possible mais vouloir
faire croire qu'effectivement et c'est
ce que le gouvernement fait en proposant
de supprimer la première tranche de
l'impôt sur le revenu regardez ce qu'ils
ont fait ils ont fait rentrer dans
l'impôt sur le revenu un tas de gens qui
n'y étaient pas ceux qui paient des
sommes effectivement assez faible de vue
le rac au double et là ils vont résultat
on va concentrer l'impôt sur le revenu
sur les classes moyennes c'est vraiment
la politique de gribouille c'est un pas
en avant deux pas en arrière je pense
qu'il faut remettre tout ça sur la table
et arrêté une position et je pense qu'il
ne faut surtout pas s'interdire une
augmentation de la tva c'est ce que le
gouvernement
se murmure un jour on nous dit oui le
lendemain on nous dit non je vous
rappelle que nous avions adopté le
principe de la tva sociale en janvier
2012 que la gauche arriver au pouvoir
s'est empressé de la supprimer et je
pense que ils ont fait une grave erreur
parce que on sait bien qu'une hausse de
la tva n'entraîne pas forcément une
augmentation des prix et surtout on met
à contribution tous les produits
importés et nous savons que nous
importons donc hausse de la tva pour
nous a été dessinée effectivement à
financer les allègements de charges pour
rendre de la compétitivité à nos
entreprises voilà donc c'est vraiment la
politique de gribouille et la
crédibilité du ministre aujourd'hui elle
est proche de zéro et c'est ça le drame
parce que l'on proposerait
rendez vous à l'automne au sénat à
l'automne exactement un autre examen de
deux projets de loi cette fois à
l'assemblée nationale il s'agit de la
transition énergétique qui a débuté
cette semaine un texte très attendu
c'était l'une des promesses de campagne
de françois hollande aujourd'hui porté
par la ministre ségolène royal qu'on va
écouter
la condition de réalisation de dépenses
dans le cadre d'un bouquet de travaux
est supprimée afin de permettre à tous
les contribuables de bénéficier du même
niveau des aides publiques quelles que
soient les opérations engagées et le
séquençage des travaux pour la ministre
qui pose un petit peu les fonds de ce
débat on a beaucoup entendu depuis
dimanche dernier quand on a fait ces
élections au sénat d'un esprit de
consensus qu'on pourrait trouver sur des
grands thèmes on voit là la transition
énergétique pourriez porter avec avec la
gauche par exemple je pense que tous les
français doivent se sentir concernés par
le problème du réchauffement climatique
d'ailleurs on constate dans l'autre pays
mois après mois des événements qu'on
n'avait pas connu le réchauffement tous
les cas sur l'analyse des choses oui il
peut y avoir consensus mai consensus à
n'est pas un gros mot dans laquelle il
peut y avoir des voix qui lisent de
constance et pour que ça puisse faire
avancer un petit peu mais parfois je
cite lacan qui disait le consensus est
le seul cas de figure où la connerie
prend du sens mais ça n'est pas toujours
le cas dans certains cas ça colle être
le cas mais pour le coup sur un thème
sur un sujet comme celui là
effectivement je pense que ce que chirac
disait ya quelques années la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs j'ai un
peu le sentiment que c'est encore vrai
le projet doit aujourd'hui par de
grandes ambitions vous ne partagez pas
mais on peut aussi on partage les
ambitions après la question c'est parce
que la france en est là ça va être la
question du financement parce qu'on sait
bien que faire en sorte que tous les
bâtiments publics et ceux des
particuliers soit effectivement mieux
saoulé et qu'on aille vers la réduction
de la consommation du gaz ou du fioul on
sait tout ça demande énormément d'argent
et du temps et de l'argent aujourd'hui
on en a plus beaucoup et par exemple si
on parle nucléaire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des centrales mais bien sûr qu'on les
garde là aussi françois hollande a été
du n'importe
qui coûtait je pense que les cécités
fera loi et qu'il sera bien obligé d'en
passer par là parce que nous n'avons pas
d'autre solution donc mais c'est le
drame de françois hollande pendant sa
campagne électorale et son fameux
discours du bourget pointant du doigt la
finance promettant monts et merveilles à
tout le monde voilà je pense qu'au fond
de lui même on avis les cours actuels il
est convaincu qu'on doit garder le
central mais cette course et
les deux d'abord parce que les centrales
les centrales nucléaires effectivement
sont beaucoup moins polluante alors il
ya le problème du retraitement des
déchets mais sont beaucoup moins
polluante que le charbon que les
allemands utilisent maintenant beaucoup
parce qu'ils ont fermé leurs centrales
nucléaires et que ne parlons pas du gaz
et du pétrole donc il faut effectivement
garder nos centrales nucléaires et puis
encore une fois 2000 milliards d'euros
de dette nous ne pourrons pas tout faire
en même temps donc je pense que ça aussi
claire en tous les cas il faudrait pour
les démanteler investir des sommes
considérables
il faudra investir également de l'argent
pour leur permettre de durer mais nous
avons un atout en france aujourd'hui
c'est ce luc les airs et une électricité
qui est moins cher qu'ailleurs on ne va
pas passer ça par pertes et profits
simplement pour plaire à madame duflot
jeudi c'est un rituel chaque année à la
reprise de la session parlementaire les
députés et les sénateurs se sont
retrouvés pour les journées
parlementaires
les communistes se sont réunis à
martigues pour leurs journées
parlementaires les verts eux et et à
amiens avec la visite du président de
l'assemblée claude bartolone puis celle
de la ministre de l'ecologie ségolène
royal la majorité tente de soigner ses
alliés et appelle au rassemblement de la
gauche
écoutez cécile duflot et jean vincent
placé
chacun a tiré le bilan de ce qui s'est
passé nous on a vu qu'on ne pouvait
avoir un accord s'ils n'étaient pas
respectées on pouvait pas faire vivre
cette coalition majoritaire mais je
crois qu'un certain nombre de
socialistes se rendre compte de la
difficulté de gouverner avec une
majorité extrêmement réduite il faut
retrouver les vertus de ce qui a été
fait ce qui était dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle
et cette dynamique là doit se retrouver
sur des propositions très précises sur
la transition énergétique sur la
biodiversité
oui la bataille budgétaire
la période ne s'y prêtait pas et puis
pour des questions d'économie tout
simplement
il faudrait vous proposer plusieurs
images en tout cas de ce qu'on appelle
des bons titres de la presse des unes de
presse qui ont fait cette semaine on a
beaucoup parlé je vous propose d'abord
regarder dans le figaro c'était des
propos qui ont été tenus visiblement par
jacques chirac qui a pris fait et cause
pour alain juppé s'il avait l'énergie
tirée directement ça serait prêt au qg
de la jupe est en tout cas et j'ai
toujours su qu'il sera au rendez vous de
son destin et celui de la france qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
jacques chirac avait qualifié à la jupe
et du meilleur d'entre nous à l'époque
je pense qu'il considère toujours
qu'alain juppé le meilleur d'entre nous
c'est parti c'est lé coup pour coup
maintenant trajet paix
mais qu'au sein de la droite
républicaine et du centre il y est
effectivement un certain nombre d'hommes
en l'occurrence mais il pourrait y avoir
des femmes qui soit en capacité de se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
avec une bonne chance d'être élus c'est
plutôt une chance pour notre camp le
taux effectivement c'est que tout cela
ne tourne pas à la guerre fratricide
avec un résultat qui pourrait être calé
non écoutez n'ont pas forcément moi je
trouve que les propos que tient elle
ajoute alain juppé y sont des propos
mesurés il n'est pas quelqu'un qui est
dans les petites phrases et ça c'est
quand même très bien
juppé fillon fillon françois fillon
il ya eu d'autres propositions qui ont
été à la une de presque pâle avec
notamment ce matin manuel valls dans la
croix vous allez le voir dans un instant
il assure que la gpa sera interdite la
gestation pour autrui tu en france il
n'y aura pas non plus de reconnaissance
automatique des faits des enfants nés à
l'étranger par procréation médicalement
assistée dimanche il va y avoir une
manifestation de la manif pour tous
justement où en êtes-vous à l'ump sur
ces questions est ce qu'il y aura un
retour si retour de la droite au pouvoir
retour sur cette loi du mariage pour
tous écoutez moi je vais vous donner mon
sentiment personnel on voit bien avec
les déclarations plus ou moins clair les
uns et des autres que c'est un sujet
compliqué juridiquement d'abord mon
sentiment c'est que il y aura
probablement pas de retour en arrière
sur la loi il faudrait d'ailleurs qu'on
m'explique juridiquement comment il
serait possible de des mariés les gens
qui se sont mariés ça pour moi ça
m'échappe enfin je suis membre de la
commission des finances est pas de la
commission des lois peut-être que mes
collègues pour m expliquer mais j'ai le
sentiment effectivement et on l'a bien
vu avec la la relative prudence de
nicolas sarkozy je pense qu' il n'y aura
pas de retour en arrière maintenant que
des garanties très sérieuse et absolue
si possible soit donné en matière de gpa
et pma je pense que c'est effectivement
ce qu'il faut obtenir et les propos de
manuel valls ce sont des propos des
propos rassurants donc maintenant on a
besoin d'un bon sens vous êtes assurés
écoutez en tous les cas la déclaration
que vous me montrez et la une de la
croix effectivement ce sont des propos
rassurants parce que la gestation pour
autrui là ça serait vraiment la ligne
jaune qui seraient franchis et je pense
que très très très majoritairement les
français ne souhaitent pas que nous
allions dans cette direction et je ne
souhaite pas non plus donc il va
effectivement falloir vous ce que le
gouvernement fera dans ce domaine donc
si on retient la leçon il n'y aura pas
d'abrogation de la loi sur le mariage
pour tous mais écoutez là je vous dis je
vous donne mon sentiment personnel
maintenant je ne sais pas qui sera élu
en 2010 elle je ne sais pas qui sera
produit et qui sera moi je pense que ce
n'est pas souhaitable et qu'on ne pourra
pas le faire de toute les manières parce
que juridiquement c'est un ça serait un
break astra est quelque part vous vous
opposez aussi là à bruno retailleau le
président du groupe m
mais il avait pris quand même des
positions assez durs contre le braille
est porteuse est mais au sein de l'ump
il ya des positions qui sont
effectivement très différente si vous
écoutez alain juppé je pense qu'il a dit
là mais j'ai dit la même chose qu alain
juppé nicolas sarkozy a été prudent et
quand j'écoute un certain nombre de mes
collègues juristes nous savons bien
qu'il y a beaucoup de difficultés là
dessus et donc moi je pense que nous ne
reviendrons pas en arrière là dessus
robecq c'est quand même un sujet qui
clivent dans votre dans votre candeur
par mike teague en france c'est vrai que
la manière dont françois hollande a
abordé le sujet était détrempée très
très clivante et cette semaine nous
allons passer aux plus de l'hebdo
consacré au retour des hommes de l'ombre
les hommes de l'ombre c'est cette série
télé politico policière sur les
coulisses du pouvoir politique les
premiers épisodes de la saison 2 était
diffusé sur france 2 un président de la
république confrontés au difficile
exercice du pouvoir une première dame
alcoolique bipolaire qui ne supportent
pas l'elysée la décomposition de
l'exécutif voilà pour le pitch les
précisions de simon barbarie
deux ans que les fans l'attendaient
cette semaine la série les hommes de
l'ombre était de retour sur france 2 et
après la conquête du pouvoir de la
saison 1 c'est son exercice qui est
illustré dans cette deuxième saison le
président de la république alain
marjorie hommes politiques de gauche
connaît des débuts difficiles à l'elysée
crise conjugale et politiques s'entre
choquent comme un petit air de déjà vu
j'ai jamais touché un sou d'argent
public aurais tu sais tout avait été
fait selon les règles médiamat que ce
serait préparé la sphère n'y a pas
d'affaires conseil est prête à faire a
demandé à la trentaine de journalistes
qui adore ce n'est pas une affaire
hissant sa retombée quand
si l'histoire emprunte à l'actualité
récente un président de la république
pas à la hauteur de la fonction pour ses
adversaires ou encore une première dame
dépressive et incontrôlable al'inverse
de son lointain cousin la série
américaine house of cards le pouvoir tel
qu'il est décrit dans les hommes de
l'ombre n'est pas un but en soi mais un
moyen de mener une action qui dépasse
les intérêts personnels on n'a jamais
intérêt dit le président le président
quel qu'il soit représente la france
doit l'aider à grandir à la hauteur de
sa fonction et non c'était du
grandiloquent à new york et si la
fiction politique à la française
respecte est un peu trop les arcanes du
pouvoir ici les compromissions et des
coups bas sont plutôt dicté par les
circonstances que par des esprits
cyniques et machiavélique alors manque
d'audace ou crédibilité les
téléspectateurs et les politiques
jugeront
alors le scénario a été écrit il ya plus
de deux ans finalement les scénaristes
ont anticipé la décomposition du pouvoir
est ce que c'était si prévisible
voilà sur une question très
difficile moi je lui je n'ai pas vu
cette série dont j'aurais du mal à en
parler il c'est vrai ce qui m'inquiète
ça peut avoir un côté sympathique
amusant ce qui m'inquiète c'est je me
demande si le téléspectateur sera faire
la différence entre la fiction et la
part de réalité parce qu'effectivement
comme il ya des ressemblances
voulu voilà où s'arrête la fiction où
commence la réalité et je suis déjà
suffisamment inquiets image très
négative de la classe politique
aujourd'hui écoutez ça peut jouer parce
qu'effectivement quand on montre
l'arrière-cour avec tout ce qui peut s'y
passer
parce que les scénaristes mais c'est
vrai mais je préfère que la justice
fasse son boulot sereinement et manière
indépendante pour régler ces problèmes
et faire en sorte que ceux qui se
comportent ainsi se retrouvent dans les
tribunaux plutôt que effectivement des
fictions qui mélange un peu tout et qui
ne feront encore qu'aggraver le
sentiment de rejet de la classe
politique parce que derrière c'est quand
même la république qui est en cause et
voulez vous ça m'inquiète en ce moment
ne riez pas écrire ou petites séries
fictions politiques
alors absolument non ce n'est pas sale
cenal favoritisme et conseillant comme
les affaires
le favoritisme les affaires comme vous y
allez il ya eu il ya eu effectivement
des choses qui qui pose question et je
le redis notamment dans le groupe ump
nous allons tâcher avec bruno retailleau
de tourner cette page là et de faire en
sorte qu effectivement plus jamais cela
ne soit possible merci beaucoup mais
philippe dallier d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation pour parlement de nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci tél